[Music]
arriving home after a long day
you settle in for a quiet evening alone
but instead of the sound of silence you
hear a constant
ringing even though there's nothing
making any noise
what you're experiencing is called
tinnitus
the perception of a noise like ringing
buzzing
hissing or clicking that occurs without
any
external source of sound tinnitus has
been bothering humanity
since ancient babylon plaguing everyone
from leonardo da vinci
to charles darwin today roughly one in
seven people
worldwide experiences this auditory
sensation
so where does this persistent sound come
from
when you normally hear something sound
waves hit
various areas of your ear creating
vibrations
that displace fluid inside the cochlea
if the vibrations are large enough they
elicit a chemical response
that transforms them into bioelectrical
signals
these nerve impulses are then relayed
through the hearing pathway
to the brain where they result in the
sounds we perceive
however in the vast majority of tinnitus
cases
the nerve signals that produce these
mysterious sounds don't travel through
your ear
at all instead they're generated
internally
by your own central nervous system
under usual circumstances these
self-produced
signals are an essential part of hearing
all mammals demonstrate ongoing neural
activity
throughout their hearing pathways when
there are no sounds present
this activity is at a baseline that
establishes your neural code
for silence when a sound does appear
this activity changes allowing the brain
to distinguish between
silence and sound but the auditory
system's health can affect this
background signal
loud noises diseases toxins
and even natural aging can damage your
cochlear cells
some of these may heal in a matter of
hours
however if enough cells die either
over time or all at once the auditory
system
becomes less sensitive with fewer
cochlear cells relaying information
incoming sounds generate weaker nerve
signals
and many environmental sounds can be
lost completely
to compensate your brain devotes more
energy
to monitoring the hearing pathway just
like you might adjust the knobs of a
radio
the brain modifies neural activity while
also tweaking the tuning knob to get a
clearer signal
increasing this background neural
activity is intended to help you process
weak auditory inputs but it can also
modify
your baseline for silence such that a
lack of sound
no longer sounds silent at all
this is called subjective tinnitus and
it accounts for the vast majority of
tinnitus cases
subjective tinnitus is a symptom
associated with practically
every known ear disorder but it isn't
necessarily
a bad thing while its appearance can be
surprising
subjective tinnitus has no inherently
negative consequences
but for some tinnitus episodes can
trigger traumatic memories
or otherwise distressing feelings which
increase the sound's intrusiveness this
psychological loop
often leads to what's known as
bothersome tinnitus
a condition that can exacerbate the
symptoms of ptsd
insomnia anxiety and depression
there's no known cure for subjective
tinnitus
so the most important thing doctors can
do is help people
understand this auditory event and
develop
neutral associations with these often
distressing
sounds for example sound therapy
uses noises like rain bird song or
music to mask tinnitus and reduce
stress one form called informational
masking
uses soothing complex auditory signals
that distract the brain from the
tinnitus sound
another called energetic masking uses
sounds with the same frequency as the
patient's tinnitus
to occupy the neurons that would
otherwise deliver the tinnitus signal
practiced alongside counseling these
interventions
allow people to re-evaluate their
relationship with tinnitus
losing the sound of silence can be
troubling to say the least
tinnitus reveals that your brain is
constantly analyzing the world around
you
even as it fails to filter its own
internal noise
in a sense experiencing tinnitus is like
eavesdropping on your brain
talking to itself though it may not be a
conversation
you want to hear as mentioned in this
video
tinnitus can be particularly difficult
for those struggling with ptsd but what
exactly
is this disorder and what steps can be
taken
to help those suffering from it learn
more with this video
or check out this video for advice on
coping with insomnia